Terremotos. Los terremotos son uno de los
fenómenos naturales que más impacto han
causado a lo largo de la historia de la humanidad.
Han destruido ciudades enteras y han segado
la vida de millones y millones de personas.
Eso no es nada nuevo.
Lo que sí es más nuevo es saber cómo resistirlos,
cómo sobrevivir y cómo hacer cada vez más
seguros los edificios y las infraestructuras.
Eso, eso, amigos, sí que es un fenómeno
muy actual.
Pero... en todo esta cuestión hay dos países
que por necesidad saben mucho.
Amigos, Chile y Japón son los dos países
más sísmicamente activos del planeta.
Cada uno de ellos concentra en torno al 20%
de todos los movimientos sísmicos que se
producen en el mundo.
De hecho, Chile es el país que ha sufrido
el terremoto más potente jamás registrado:
el terremoto de Valdivia en 1960. Tuvo una
magnitud de 9,5 en la escala de Richter. Un
verdadero cataclismo.
Japón como Chile están enclavados
en pleno Cinturón de Fuego, una franja de
40.000 kilómetros que constituye la región
de la Tierra con más actividad sísmica y
volcánica.
En esta zona, las placas tectónicas subducen,
es decir, una se introduce por debajo de la
otra, generando zonas de subducción.
Ese movimiento no es constante ni regular,
sino que sucede a tirones, y cuando ambas
placas están muy tensas y con mucha energía
acumulada, ceden, se sueltan y se mueven de
golpe, generando fuertes terremotos.
Este es el motivo por el que en el Cinturón
de Fuego se producen el 90% de todos los terremotos
en el mundo y el 80% de los más potentes,
los megathrust.
De hecho, los terremotos de Japón y Chile
son muy similares en magnitud y duración.
Podéis imaginar que con semejante reto hay
que elegir: adaptarse o pasarlo muy, pero
que muy mal.
Hoy, en VisualPolitik, os contamos cómo lo han
hecho, cuáles son las principales diferencias
entre ambos y el gran reto común al que se
enfrentan Japón y Chile.
Atentos.
(CHILE Y JAPÓN, APRENDER A BASE DE GOLPES)
Amigos, los terremotos más destructivos tienen
consecuencias terribles. Hablamos de fenómenos
que pueden acabar con la vida de decenas y
decenas de miles de personas en apenas unos
pocos minutos.
Chile y Japón son los países más avanzados
en prevención de desastres sísmicos por
una sencilla razón, a lo largo de su historia
han vivido terribles tragedias que les han
enseñado una lección muy valiosa:
merece la pena gastar más al principio para
ahorrar costes humanos y de reconstrucción.
Pero…. Para ver más claro la magnitud de
lo que estamos hablando pongamos un ejemplo.
Todavía está en la retina de todos.
El 11 de marzo de 2011 es una de esas fechas
que seguro todos podemos recordar.
Ese día un enorme terremoto de magnitud 9,1
se originó en la Prefectura de Miyagi, en
Japón, pero sacudió buena parte del país,
incluida la capital, Tokyo.
El Gran Terremoto del Este y el posterior
tsunami dejaron a sus espaldas casi 16.000 fallecidos
y más de 6.000 heridos. Y sí, hablamos del
terremoto que terminó causando el desastre
de Fukushima.
Este ha sido el último megaterremoto en Japón,
pero, amigos, los japoneses saben que hay
un 70% de posibilidades de que un megaterremoto
suceda en Tokyo durante los próximos 30 años.
Y sí, vale, es verdad que la gran mayoría,
más del 85% de los edificios de Tokyo se
consideran resistentes, pero el hecho de haya
16.000 hectáreas cubiertas por edificios
de madera en la capital japonesa no ayuda.
Según algunas simulaciones los escapes de
gas producidos por un gran terremoto podrían
causar incendios por toda la ciudad y destruir
más de 600 mil edificios.
Las consecuencias van mucho más allá de
los temblores y los posibles derrumbes.
Y claro, todo esto es algo que genera conciencia;
social y política.
En Chile, por su parte, van algo por detrás
pero el shock social del 2010 hizo que se
tomase aún más en serio la prevención de
riesgos.
(Un terremoto
de 8,8 grados de magnitud sacude Chile.
El terremoto, de un minuto de duración, pudo
sentirse en la capital, donde se interrumpió
el servicio eléctrico. El maremoto causado
por el seísmo llega a Hawai. La vanguardia
(El terremoto de Chile fue horrible, pero pudo haber sido mucho peor.
Chile es uno de los países más ricos y mejor organizados de Sudamérica y
muchos de sus hogares y oficinas fueron construidos para ser resistentes a los terremotos.)
Amigos, el terremoto de Chile afectó al 70%
de la población del país, pero... gracias
a las regulaciones anti sísmicas, por ejemplo,
tan solo dos construcciones en altura se desplomaron
en la capital, Santiago.
Y eso, ante un terremoto así es en cierto
modo todo un éxito, especialmente teniendo
en cuenta los precedentes en una región como
Latinoamérica.
("Las inversiones de Chile en infraestructura
resiliente, sistemas de alerta temprana y
planificación urbana han logrado asegurar
que en esta ocasión el número de víctimas
sea bajo, a pesar de la intensidad del terremoto".
Margareta Wahlström, ex-Representante Especial
de la Oficina de las Naciones Unidas para
la Reducción del Riesgo de Desastres.)
Y esto es, amigos, en lo que hay que incidir.
Ya lo dice el proverbio: mejor prevenir que
curar.
Pero, ¿cómo han conseguido Japón y Chile
lograr estos niveles de prevención de riesgos?
¿Existen diferencias entre ambos modelos?
¿Cuáles son las debilidades y las claves
para salvar vidas?
(SI HAY RIESGO, ADELÁNTATE A ÉL)
Cuando hablamos de terremotos debemos tener
dos cosas muy en cuenta: son impredecibles
e inevitables.
Sin embargo, lo que sí se puede predecir
y evitar son los riesgos derivados de los
terremotos.
Veréis, ante un terremoto la prevención
puede ser de dos tipos: activa y pasiva.
Por ejemplo, Tras el terremoto de Valdivia
de 1960, el más fuerte jamás registrado
que causó un tsunami enorme, se creó el
Sistema de Advertencia y Mitigación de Tsunamis
del Pacífico por la Comisión Oceanográfica
Intergubernamental de la UNESCO en 1965, con
el objetivo de difundir alertas tempranas
de tsunami.
Tranquilos, no os asustéis porque sea tan
antiguo....El sistema se ha ido actualizando
con el paso del tiempo.
El caso es que ese es uno de los mejores ejemplos
de prevención activa.
Un tsunami en el Pacífico tiene una enorme
capacidad de propagación, y son potencialmente
muy destructivos.
Normalmente pasan unos 20 o 30 minutos entre
que se produce un terremoto debajo o próximo
al mar y el tsunami golpea la costa más cercana.
Pero en el caso del terremoto de Japón de
2011 en algunas zonas tan solo pasaron 2 minutos
entre la alerta y el tsunami.
Y claro, tratándose de fenómenos que requieren
de evacuaciones masivas y que afectan a regiones
inmensas, las alertas tempranas son sumamente
importantes, muy importantes. Cuanto más
tiempo haya mejor que mejor. Cada segundo
cuenta.)
De hecho, un terremoto fuerte originado en
Chile puede provocar un tsunami tan grande
que afecte a costas muy alejadas como las
japonesas, neozelandesas, estadounidenses
e incluso filipinas.
El caso, amigos, es que precisamente por eso
Japón también cuenta con su propio sistema
de alerta temprana, muy mejorado, por cierto,
tras la catástrofe del 2011.
Desde ese año se han invertido más de 25
mil millones de dólares en sensores sísmicos
terrestres para llegar a los 280, la red más
densa y fiable del mundo.
Sin embargo, el mayor reto con mucha diferencia
es la prevención pasiva, es decir, todas
esas medidas y normas que buscan minimizar
los daños en las construcciones, y por tanto
las víctimas.
Y esto Japón es el líder indiscutible.
(El estricto código de construcción de Japón salva vidas. The New York Times)
Pero, ¿en qué consiste exactamente?
Pues...Fijaos.
A pesar de que la primera normativa antisísmica
para la construcción en Japón data de 1924,
en la actualidad la mayor parte de los edificios
están construidos bajo dos normativas muy
diferentes.
La antigua, llamada kyu-taishin, data de 1950,
y se centraba en evitar el derrumbe de los
edificios. La nueva o shin-taishin ,de 1981,
exige que en terremotos de medios a fuertes
el edificio como mucho presente algunas grietas,
pero pueda seguir utilizándose.)
Estas normas, evidentemente, se han ido reforzando
parcialmente con el paso de los años.
Es precisamente por esto que las estructuras
de los edificios en Japón son mayoritariamente
de acero, mucho más flexible y resistente
a los movimientos, en lugar del rígido hormigón.
Además en algunos casos también se instalan
vigas transversales que absorben energía
del terremoto.
Y por supuesto cuentan también con amortiguadores
sísmicos en la base de los edificios más
altos.
Chile, por el contrario, no exige que los
edificios no sufran daños sino que la normativa
se orienta más a que no se vengan abajo.
Su normativa actual se parece un poco más
a la japonesa de 1950.
Con esto podéis daros cuenta de la enorme
diferencia de visión que tienen en Chile,
donde la regulación es mucho menos estricta.
Es decir en Chile se busca salvar vida pero
sin que sea necesario que los edificios queden
indemnes .
Y esto tiene una explicación fundamental:
el coste.
Construir un edificio tan resistente como
los de Japón puede costar en torno a un 10
o un 15% más que uno más común.
Y claro, eso hace que los precios de las viviendas
en edificios más nuevos y resistentes sean
más caros. La filosofía es: “Si vives
aquí, estarás seguro”.
Pero, esperad un momento.
Estamos dando por hecho que las normas siempre
se cumplen, que todo es bonito y sencillo,
cuando la realidad puede ser diferente.
De hecho, ¿sabéis cuál es el principal
problema que afecta a la seguridad y puede
costar muchas vidas?
Pensadlo un momento… Exacto, habéis acertado.
(ATENCIÓN, LA CORRUPCIÓN MATA)
Sí, habéis escuchado bien.
No es que la corrupción sea mala sino que es que mata.
Puede que te sorprenda pero la corrupción
es, sin lugar a dudas, la mayor amenaza para
la seguridad en caso de terremotos.
Y no, no os creáis que Japón y Chile están
libres de esta lacra porque, aunque Japón
tenga esa imagen de país ideal y Chile esté
en un decente puesto 27 en el índice de percepción
de la corrupción, de vez en cuando saltan
escándalos como este.
La KYB Corporation, una empresa japonesa dedicada
al desarrollo y fabricación de amortiguadores
sísmicos, aceptó a finales de 2018 haber
falseado durante más de una década los datos
de calidad y rendimiento de sus productos.
A día de hoy, todavía no se ha podido cuantificar
el alcance real del riesgo que esto supone,
pero se estima que la efectividad de los productos
falseados podría rondar el 86% de los requisitos
mínimos que exige la Ley.
Edificios tan importantes como el Ayuntamiento
de Tokyo, el Centro Acuático Olímpico y
el Ariake Arena, sede de los Juegos Olímpicos
de 2020, utilizan amortiguadores sísmicos
de esta empresa.
Y por si esto fuera poco, la torre más alta
del mundo, también.
(La Tokyo Skytree, entre los edificios relacionados con el escándalo
de datos del fabricante de amortiguadores sísmicos KYB Corp. The Japan Times.)
Eso sí, aunque como veis este caso es muy
grave, lo cierto es que Japón es un país
poco corrupto, y eso hace que las regulaciones
antisísmicas se cumplan la inmensa mayoría
de las veces.
Chile, por su parte, tiene el menor nivel
de corrupción de toda Latinoamérica, lo
que ha contribuido a que las normativas antisísmicas
en la construcción se cumplan en la inmensa
mayor parte de los casos.
Aunque eso sí, como ya hemos visto, son menos,
mucho menos exigentes que las de Japón.
(“Tenemos una ley que señala que los diseños
de cierta altura tienen que ser revisados
por un equipo independiente que verifica que
se esté cumpliendo con la norma. Nadie construye
sin un respaldo de este tipo”. Sergio Sepúlveda,
académico de geología de la Universidad
de Chile)
Pero… ¿Sabés qué? Es precisamente este
amplio cumplimiento de las normativas lo que
hace que Chile sea un país muchísimo más
seguro que, por ejemplo, México para vivir
un terremoto.
(Corrupción y negligencia causaron derrumbes
en el sismo de Ciudad de México. EFE)
La diferencia
con Chile es que en las ciudades de México
cada vez que se produce un terremoto fuerte
varios edificios se derrumban, dejando numerosas
víctimas.
Y aunque es cierto que no todos los terremotos
tienen las mismas características, por ejemplo
por el tipo de suelo y la profundidad, en
el terremoto del 19 de septiembre de 2017
perdieron la vida, tan solo en la capital,
Ciudad de México, 228 personas, 369 en todo
el país.
En cambio en Chile, el terremoto del año
2015 en Coquimbo, que se sintió con intensidad
7 en Santiago, tan solo causó 15 víctimas
mortales en todo el país.
Todo un ejemplo de preparación antisísmica.
Por esto, amigos, México y otros países
altamente sísmicos deben ponerse las pilas